[Applause]
get up here alright yeah
ghostbusters - what can one say about
ghostbusters - well it's the second one
yeah so I get that a lot of people
didn't like the 2016 reboot hell for me
it just went in one ear and out the
other like 30 seconds of elevator music
but I do kind of lose it when people say
oh the franchise Oh like really did you
all sit through the second one cuz woof
hey fans remember those chain-smoking
boosts willing swearing Ghostbusters
from the first movie well now they're
dancing with toasters hosting kids
birthday parties and playing with babies
oh how cute
remember when this guy used to zap dudes
to hit on college chicks that's okay cuz
now he's shacking up with the single mom
he once shot up with enough Thorazine to
kill a herd of elephants wait they're
not together anymore uh-oh we got to
start over here we go again
but it's okay cuz we got Winston
remember him neither do we
cuz he's still missing from half the
movie here we go again
is that Peck no it's diet pack here we
go again
guess the city doesn't believe in ghosts
now here we go again whoa ghost running
around the city here we go again
look Janene 2.0 is still hitting on
nerds here we go again
remember when Janine and Peter had an
antagonistic relationship well now she
babysits for him here we go again ray
says I Love You Man and hugs it out with
a guy who loves him back as the whole
city sings with brotherly love here we
know okay that never happened in the
first one you get the idea though now
I'm not saying you can't like the second
film I like it or well parts but I kind
of see it as a guilty pleasure it's not
a great movie and it certainly bears no
tonal resemblance to the original so
what went wrong
well first no one wanted to make it Ivan
Reitman the Harold Ramos and Dan a-kor
I'd already thought the first film
covered everything but the studio pretty
much said listen guys this will get made
with or without you so how about you
just take our nice big check and COFF
something up and then the three of them
were like the second thing is this
there's an interesting theory out there
that Ghostbusters is essentially a movie
about nothing and I agree that's not a
criticism far from it my favorite movie
of all time is the Big Lebowski and that
movie is a movie about nothing but the
problem is you can't have lightning
strike twice a sequel about nothing is
incredibly difficult to do so the
creators tried emphasis on tried to
spice it up by bringing in themes of
fatherhood accepting responsibility
and be excellent to each other I guess
and that's not the problem you kind of
have to do that at this point the issue
is they wanted it both ways though hey
let's make a movie about something but
also just remake the movie about nothing
and it doesn't work you got to come up
with something fresher if you're gonna
do this not saying you can't hit some of
the same notes but this is literally
ghostbusters one with all the edge
removed but did it have to be this way
could it be saved well I don't know
about that but I think a few changes
could have gone a long way and I think
it could have been done without having
to completely ditch the bones of the
film's plot so let's get started
so we open with Dana Barrett walking
down a New York City sidewalk first
things first
no baby she stops by a newspaper stand
and sees a headline about the
Ghostbusters they're going on trial
today she picks it up and stares at it
the newspaper vendor strikes up a
conversation oh you following that yeah
I think it said these guys saved the
city from a 60-foot marshmallow man and
then every agency in the state Sue's
them for damages I mean how long has
this been dragging on five years jeez I
don't even want to think about it Dana
sighs and buys the paper well it's hard
not to think about it when it's your
fiancee jump cut to Peter Venkman with
the rest of the gang awaiting for court
to start in court we get treated to
pretty much the same deal as the
original totally is representing them
because they've run out of money the
judge is a skeptic maybe we can figure
out what the ghostbusters have been up
to via their testimony you know ray runs
a book shop Egon steals kids puppies
Winston does birthday parties and peter
has a lame psychic show the kicker is
Peck is back and he testifies against
them smugly grinning at Peter the whole
time as Peter himself testifies about
the unknown we dive beneath to the old
Van Horne station a river of blood red
slime flows through the tunnel and yes
make it the color of blood Viggo was
supposed to be a Vlad the Impaler type
so let's try to make it a little scarier
any way we cut to a crack in the ground
and watch the slime rise back in court
the case draws to a close and the judge
reads them the right act as he's
screaming at them the bloody slime rises
from a crack beneath his feet and the
scolari Brothers emerge the Ghostbusters
are allowed to defeat them just like in
the original and they emerge triumphant
with Peter shouting
boom we just accomplished in a few
minutes what it took a third of the
original film to do cuz ya
keep in mind after an exciting movie in
multiple seasons of the cartoon show
what kid wanted to see the Ghostbusters
as losers who can't bust ghosts for 30
minutes I mean you can keep the
bureaucratic commentary but get to the
point so we return to Dana who's exiting
a hospital she catches the news on the
Ghostbusters Court victory on a store TV
display and bolts we then cut to the
firestation janine melnitz takes a call
oh yeah no they are indisposed yeah I
wouldn't call again I have a feeling
they're gonna be gone for a long time
she hangs up grabs a suitcase and heads
for the door the Ghostbusters bustin
triumphant Peter asks Jeanine to put
some coffee on Glee we pay you for this
Jeanine seems unimpressed great Dana
walks in looking distraught Peter asks
why she wasn't in the courtroom she says
she has something important to tell him
but a couple of cops walk in
ghostbusters mayor wants to speak with
you Peter says sorry honey daddy's got a
hot dog with the elites at the mayor's
office a fight rages between the
politicians as the Ghostbusters look on
the mayor wants the Ghostbusters to
investigate the haunting at the
courthouse but Peck is incredulous the
once skeptical judge is there defending
the Ghostbusters I know when I saw Peck
shoots back I can't believe you're
taking this ghost nonsense seriously are
you calling a district judge a liar Peck
backs down and smiles maybe we can come
to a compromise then it's settled
the mayor says looks like the
Ghostbusters are back in business we
then cut to Dana restoring a painting
while Janos hits on her she seems
distraught in the midst it's about Peter
and their future together Janos tries to
convince her that Peter is no good for
her
put off by Yano she decides to take work
off early and go talk to Peter back at
the station we see the gang turning the
containment unit back on while Lois
unloads their financial situation all
I'm saying is you're gonna need to make
at least $300,000 in the first quarter
alone to cover half your outstanding
debt Peter brushes him off his fine so
long as old rusty here works ray flips a
switch
alright she's ready
go ray says Winston holds up a couple of
smoking traps let's say a Reba dirty to
the Scoleri brothers just then Peck
walks in hold it right there
I have a cease-and-desist forbidding you
from using this containment unit Ray
protests but the mayor said the mayor
agrees with me Peck shoots back this
facility was involved in a major
explosion and until this storage unit is
fully vetted by the EPA you can hunt
ghosts but you can't store them here
Peter asks and how long will this
vetting take Peck smiles
well we're backlogged but given the
usual channels in the paperwork for
years this is absurd Peter says we'll be
out of business
Peck gets uncomfortably close it's
simple capitalism dr. Venkman adapt or
die
Peck leaves and Peter asks what else
could go wrong
suddenly Dana walks in Peter I'm
pregnant an awkward beat as the gang
gives Peter some space so Peter and Dana
talk elsewhere Peter asks how this could
happen to which Dana shoots back I don't
know Peter maybe it was the protection
you bought at the dollar store she
admits that she doesn't know what to do
she gave up touring the world with the
orchestra for him and since then he's
still the same he never takes anything
seriously the businesses in shambles and
she worries that maybe it was just never
meant to work out Peter replies with you
told me that once and what did I say I'd
solve your little problem and then
you'll say Peter Venkman is a guy who
can get things done Peter returns to the
gang in the basement ray asks so Peter
says we need to figure something out
when five years ago we then cut to
Janusz at night he gets sat by Viggo
it's pretty much the same deal except
Viggo is looking for someone to bear his
child he needs a queen in the marriage
ceremony needs to happen by New Year's
Eve yada yada yada of a seven Dana so
now the first act has set up the entire
movie and it stakes
Peter needs to get his shit together the
Ghostbusters need to get their shit
together and they need new tech to get
rid of the ghosts and they all need to
solve the mystery of what's causing this
recent spate of hauntings and on top of
that yawn ocean Viggo have designs I'm
Dana so how do they solve all these
problems first Rainey you gotta work on
a new device to trap ghosts ray explains
that they use transdimensional cross
theory similar to what happened with
Gozer in theory a number of demons
demigods floors and supplicants enter
our realm from another ghostly dimension
so instead of storing ghosts in a
containment unit why not boot them to
another dimension
after all the door swings both ways
blast them opened a portal throw them in
and lock the door
as Peter notes are you telling me the
universe runs like New York City we just
ship our trash across the river and make
it Jersey's problem ray says more or
less I love it Venkman replies so rainy
that you got essentially construct a
portable mini cannon which fires remote
minds that can cling to walls and
ceilings the mind will then be detonated
by button the Ghostbusters will carry on
them push it to open push it again to
close they decide to test it out in the
firehouse they release one of the
Scolari brothers blast him fire the
cannon open a portal in the ceiling lead
him up to the hole and then watch as he
gets sucked in
once gallery disappears races I think
I'd call that a success then the giant
monster tries to escape from the portal
scaring the hell out of them they scream
and Egon shouts close it off ray hits
the button then the portal closes Peter
says ok important safety tip always shut
the door behind you Winston asks so what
do we do now ray says let's bust some
ghosts and here's the perfect time for a
montage we get the goofy commercial the
driving scenes the busting seen some
horrific we dated 90s wrath the whole
nine yards after that we cut to the
courthouse at night where the gang is
investigating the scolari incident they
follow a series of cracks into the
basement and find a hole with the team
woefully out of shape they send Winston
down and he finds the old van Hoorn
station with the river of blood slime he
accidentally falls in and sees horrific
visions of demons torturing ghosts and
on top of a pile of skulls laughing
Stan's Vigo Vigo x' image turns to
Winston
the team pulls him out just in time but
just like in the original he trips on a
wire and causes a blackout above ground
Winston is suffering from PTSD from the
experience he explains that the slime is
like pure fear terror and horror all
rolled into one and there was something
else there it's like it was feeding off
all the destruction the slime was
causing so yeah I guess my thing here is
that Vigo is kind of like the hip spider
he feeds on fear which makes him
stronger which makes more slime which
makes more hauntings which makes more
fear which makes him stronger you get it
it's a feedback loop the slime stirs up
ghosts and the more scared the city is
the stronger Vigo grows across town dana
is working late on restoring a painting
when the lights go out she finds a
flashlight and hears noises she explores
the museum and the unthinkable happens
the paintings come to life and reach out
for her
she screams then some armor or
terracotta warriors or something come to
life it's a museum you know use your
imagination anyway she drops the
flashlight him runs the next day the
mayor unleashes his wrath on the gang
Peck is pleased I told you not to trust
these men
the mayor orders him off the
investigation and says if there's one
more slip-up they'll be shut down for
good at the station
Randi got notice a pattern to all their
bus they follow a straight line then ray
overlays an old map of the Van Horne
line they match up now the slime was
flowing this way Winston says Peter asks
where the old line ended they look in
races oh no it's the Art Museum Peter
shows up at the Museum to meet Dana and
says there might be a connection has she
seen anything she mentions the incident
the night before but thought it was just
exhaustion then she mentions how she
feels that the Vigo painting is always
staring at her we then cut to the whole
gang showing up like stuck in the cuts
guys were the Ghostbusters right away
Winston points to the painting and says
to Egon that's him that's the guy I saw
on the slide Winston keeps his distance
clearly frightened the rest of the scene
plays out like the original right down
to the Carpathian kitten loss but with
one key difference after taunting Vigo
its Peter who gets glared at by the
painting and zones out back at the
firehouse they analyze the pictures
and Winston says that that's the river
of slime he fell into right behind
Viggo's ugly mug the pictures then set
on fire this time Peter bust the door
down and Jeannine flies in with a fire
extinguisher as the smoke clears they
explained the situation to Peter he then
asked what this has to do with Dana ray
and Egon note that there was a legend
that Viggo will return with a bride and
the child by his side like some unholy
Nativity but why Dana ray there's
millions of women in the city ray
answers you forget think man only one
was touched by the supernatural your
fiancee up at spook central so because
of her encounter with Gozer she's
basically on every spooks radar to quote
ray you sure know how to pick them Peter
[Music]
now I want to take a second and talk
about a couple of characters I haven't
mentioned much what about Janine and
Lewis alright I'm just gonna say it I
can't stand what they did to Janine in
the sequel like who is this I'm not
saying she can't date Lewis but did they
have to turn her into such a cartoon
character to do it why can't a woman
just like a nerd she liked to egon but
no we can't accept that we've got to go
full Big Bang Theory on her it's funny
because they're dorks I mean if you want
to make them romantic do it organically
let it develop because I do think they
work as a duo they're essentially the B
team so I thought a fun filler story
might be that janina's convinced the
firehouse has a pest problem there's
noises missing food scratches on the
wall eventually she discovers it's
Slimer thus begins this game of
cat-and-mouse between her and the ghosts
maybe she tries scaring him off maybe
she tries activating one of the old
traps in front of a bucket of fried
chicken she left out his bait
eventually Lewis gets involved and they
kind of hit it off while trying to solve
this problem this leads up to a scene
where Dana shows up to meet Peter for a
dinner date basically where Peter is
going to explain everything about
Viggo's plan because Dana is early she
spots Janine and Lewis trying to figure
out how to turn a proton pack on all of
them are whispering as Slimer gorges
himself at the fridge the three of them
figure it out together
Dana says it has to be this button
Jeannine fires it and misses she ends up
blowing a hole in the wall Peter walks
in and Jeanine shoves the proton pack
and Lewis's hands and tells him to hide
it Peter looks at the flaming wall and
asks what the hell happened electrical
fire I told you this place with a
deathtrap Peter explains that if the
place needs to be rewired they'll have
to cut the salaries of all non-essential
personnel he then leads Dana out Dana
and turn shrugs at Janine like yeah
sorry I know he's a dick so Peter and
Dana go on their dinner date meanwhile
ray Egon and Winston consult Tobin's
spirit guide and find out that Viggo had
a cursed wedding ring which would tie
his spirit to the wearer it's on display
at the city's History Museum is part of
the Carpathian collection now it all
makes sense this is why Vigo chose New
York they decide to go there suspecting
it'll be pill
by ghosts at the Museum the Ghostbusters
run into a number of ghosts and Janos
decked out like some ghostly Grim Reaper
or something they fight a valiant battle
and a great action scene but Janos gets
away with the ring and the museum well
it's a mess
across town Peter lays out the whole
story to Dana she questions whether this
relationship is worth it I mean let's
face it Peter you're not good for me I'm
not good for me but I thought a Sumerian
demigod to hold on to you Father who
it's only slightly more terrifying but
if I really am marked as Egon and Rhea
say then I'll be nothing but trouble
perhaps it'd be easier on all of you if
I just left no see that's why we got to
stick together they'll have your back
I'll have your back
who else you give a call it is literally
our slogan suddenly the Ghostbusters
bust in smoldering slimed and looking
like they've been through hell they
explained that Viggo has the ring Dana
has to hide cut to a random cop
receiving a call its Janos on the other
line he lies and says he works at the
History Museum where the Ghostbusters
have destroyed numerous priceless
artifacts meanwhile Peter puts Dana up
in a hotel she insists she'll be fine
and tells Peter to work with the team on
a solution he decides to leave but
insists he'll return with his proton
pack on the drive back an active one the
team brainstorms ideas all agree that
now they're behind the eight-ball rain
notes that Viggo had to have some
enemies maybe they can call on them from
the other side they can use the slime
they collected in the old van Hoorn
station to find a trace signature this
will give them the right dimension to
tap into but someone would need to go in
there who just then the team pulls up to
the firehouse cop cars are everywhere
the equipment is being seized Peck
stands by and watches Peter accuses him
of trying to ruin them but Peck explains
that he has nothing to do with it this
is the mayor's doing dr. Venkman he told
you one more slip-up and you're through
well apparently your friends here
destroyed countless priceless artifacts
then why are you here Peter asks oh I'm
just here for the show popcorn peck
passes a bag of Street popcorn he's been
munching on a short beet and jump cut to
the ghostbusters standing outside their
fire house which is now sealed with
police tape a whole museum huh good job
guys
what's your encore you got
of the Empire State Building as Ray
Peter and Egon argue with each other
Winston steps in hey guys don't you find
it a little coincidental how this all
happened at once I mean now we're
defenseless it's almost like something's
trying to split us apart ray asks but
why would anyone want to split us apart
it suddenly hits Peter Dana so he and
the gang bolt towards the hotel inside
Dana's hotel room we got a replay of the
original bathtub scene this time I'd
have it be the outline of Viggo himself
rising from the tub covered in slime
reaching out to her it says she screams
and runs for the door the door slams she
looks at the window down below the
Ghostbusters pull up they see Dana on
the ledge above Peter shout said he's
coming up but Ray says look instead of
the baby carriage from the original it's
a haunted black wedding carriage being
driven by a crazed Janos he pulls up
next to her and produces a bouquet of
black roses my lady he says your
carriage awaits
Jana she extends his arms and pulls her
into the carriage the door locks and he
takes off ray says it's over Spangler no
ray he replies I think it's just
starting they look up at the sky a
magical storm gathers lightning strikes
the night sky goes blood-red underground
the red slime completely engulfs the old
van Hoorn station and this is where I
figure we could get the classic
ghostbusters supernatural montage only
this time there's a bit of a twist one
of the problems with the original sequel
is that we've already seen ghosts
running amok in New York City so why not
switch it up a little
I'd have Vigo's demonic army of the
undead rise up from the river of slime
and possess all the city statues think
about it imagine all these icons coming
to life and running amok like the Atlas
statue in Rockefeller Plaza swinging
around his globe a torus
maybe the Prometheus statue Earl's
fireballs and ice skaters the running
bull chases stockbrokers down Wall
Street considering all of the artwork
around New York City this would be a
great love letter to the city itself and
most of it would just be costuming and
mat work so we get a montage of these
statues marching around the streets they
stop at the Museum and surround it like
an army at City Hall this
the officials are in a panic the
ghostbusters have air pleading to get
their equipment back as the city leaders
lay out the disaster unfolding Peck sits
in the corner stone-cold silent the
mayor turns to him and I'm sure your
position is we shouldn't trust these men
Peck speaks actually mr. mayor I think
they should be given whatever resources
are necessary and what the hell brought
there that did you see Jesus or
something
no Peck replies I had a long
heart-to-heart with my mother last night
and that convinced you three things Peck
says one my mother said I was being
petty to these nice boys too I trust my
mother more than anyone else on the
planet
three my mother's been dead for the last
fourteen years Peter seems incredulous
so that's it huh after all this time you
just cut the red tape and we're legit
what do you want from us Peck gets
uncomfortably close and stares Peter
down I want you to do what I do every
day dr. Venkman your job
so Peck here kind of gets a little
Redemption which i think is important
one it takes him beyond one note and two
it might give William Atherton something
to chew on since he regretted taking the
role in the first place I'm a count of
everybody calling him dickless and
honestly I'd want him back
because their other option essentially
Peck 2.0 just felt like a downgrade and
no I'm not slamming Kurt fuller this guy
is an amazing comedic actor watch him in
Psych if you want to see him at his best
but he's completely wasted here because
the creators pretty much wanted him to
be Peck so the mayor asked the
Ghostbusters what they need and Ray
admits that there's not much that the
city can do we need outside help he says
so surrounded by National Guard troops
the Ghostbusters suit Winston up they've
analyzed the signature of the slime
which will give them the gateway to the
right dimension they plug their
coordinates into the remote cannon the
gang gasps Winston if he's sure about
this he says that having fallen into the
slime he's tasted fear knowing what it's
like to come in contact with something
from the other side he's the only one
best equipped to do this Viggo's
tortured and killed thousands during his
lifetime ray says he fed off their fear
to grow his own power he's probably
still feeding on it there's got to be
some spirits over there with an
to grind find them and bring them back
we'll meet you at the Museum see you on
the other side Winston see you on the
other side Rey
so Winston hops through the portal and
yes this gives something for Winston to
do and inside the ghost dimension things
can get really wild imagine seeing the
sort of place where a being like dozer
would come from
maybe it's very sci-fi maybe it's like
some Hieronymus Bosch style hellscape
whatever it is the Mad painters and
special effects animators could have a
field day
so Winston finds the victims of Vigo
impaled peasants soldiers killed in
Viggo's wars and they tried to scare him
off after all he doesn't belong there
but Winston pushes back and gives a
badass speech you know something to the
effect of I've fought 60-foot
marshmallow men and mouldy old
Babylonian gods to which the ghost
replies you mean closer
yeah it's Sumerian whatever point being
I'm not afraid of you you're scared and
I get that I felt that fear but you've
got to face it and fight it think
Aragorn summoning the army of the Dead
and Return of the King that sort of
thing the spirits tell them that Viggo's
minions are too many and that the city
is too scared they would need to take
charge of something so huge so good that
it would inspire the masses and break
his evil hold on the city Winston has an
idea meanwhile the Ghostbusters approach
the museum and see the line of statues
they charge their blasters the crowd
roars back at the portal Winston emerges
with a bunch of ghosts the National
Guard is ready to shoot but Winston
explains that they're the good guys the
guards ask Winston what he needs he says
a boat somewhere in here we cut to Dana
pretty much like the other film she's
locked behind doors as Janos hits on her
he explains the plan Vigo will possess
him and they will be Wed Dana seems
unenthused Janos hears cheering outside
and leaves to investigate outside the
Ghostbusters begin fighting and get
their asses handed to them there's just
too many statues and the proton packs
can't seem to penetrate the marble and
the steel they seem magically invincible
we then cut to Winston who's at the base
of the
something we don't know what yet but
he's looking up he turns to the ghost
you think there's enough of you to
possess something this big the lead
ghost nods then I sure hope this works
alright boys start er up the ghost swirl
around Winston and fly up off-camera
creating mighty flashes of light back at
the Museum the Ghostbusters are
crouching behind some debris trying to
regroup it's no use races the city is
scared city scared I'm scared
you don't get it think then fear is what
gives me go is power unless there's
something I can snap the city out of it
we're doomed
jnos stands atop the roof taunting them
you elect the buzzing of flies to Vigo
Venkman swears he'll take the little
worm down to which yeah no shouts yeah
dr. Venkman
you and what army just then there's a
whistle everyone turns it's Winston yo
guys there's a large series of booms and
here we get the big reveal it's the
Statue of Liberty come to life possessed
by thousands of ghosts Winston points to
the statues and yawn oh Sh sicko here we
get something a little more punchy than
the original where the statue was just
walking around I guess in this version
she steps on all the statues guarding
the museum
maybe picks them up and tosses them and
as the crowd cheers at the sight the
barriers around the museum start to
crumble finally Lady Liberty picks up
the Atlas statues globe and bowls it
right through the front door inside yeah
no she's already grabbed Dana and
brought her to the makeshift altar in
front of the painting shouting viga you
must die they are coming just then the
door busts open and the an ocean dana
dive out of the way of the rolling globe
Peter shouts taffy no yeah Peter and
Dana embrace and they all stare at the
painting races let's blast him but Janos
jumps in front of them like a human
shield and tries to grab their blasters
ray Egon Winston and Dana tussle with
Janos while Peter slowly walks away he's
fixated on the painting it glares at him
Dana slaps Janos across the face he
falls
Winston points the blaster at his head
play it cool 'no the gang then stares at
peter his proton pack falls to the
ground then we see the painting hey it's
gone ray says so yeah the painting is
there but
Viggo is missing Dana asks Peter what
happened Peter suddenly Peter turns
around eyes glowing teeth sharpened
bearing an uncanny resemblance to Viggo
much like the original he explains in
the demonic voice that Peter is no more
there was only now this is actually a
nod to something that the cartoon did
that I thought was brilliant see there
was an episode where Peter gets
possessed by a ghost and shuts down the
containment unit and incant me thinking
why did that feel so much better with
Peter than with Ray and I realized well
ray he's kind of an idiot possessing him
doesn't seem like a challenge but Peter
he's the anchor the mouth the skeptic
the one who just doesn't get fazed by
anything as a kid he always felt kind of
safe untouchable even so they have him
get possessed would carry more weight
anyway possessed Peter knocks the
Ghostbusters back with his black magic
paralyzing them he then reaches for Dana
who's pulled to him by some unseen force
he then forced pulls Janos up to the
altar and orders him to officiate Janos
starts having second thoughts but Viggo
zaps and back into place okay okay fine
Dana do you Peter interrupts
Janos continues and obviously you do so
huh just the place sitting I guess and
it's all over the demonic Peter pulls
her hand out and tries to place the ring
on it
Dana resists Peter she pleads fighting
him you said you'd always have my back
you said you wanted to be a father and
now you're gonna hand me and your child
over to this monster that's not the
Peter I know the ghostbusters join in
urging Peter to fight demonic Peter
nearly puts the ring on her finger but
pulls back and shouts Peter is at war
with himself now he phases in and out of
Vigo and Venkman we cut to Dana who's
putting Peter's proton pack on she arms
the blaster Peter she shouts the demonic
Venkman turns to face her she fires the
blaster splitting vigoss ghost from
venkman's body the other Ghostbusters
are freed and get off they opened fire
Peter then stumbles up and approaches
Dana
you mind Peter asks Dana takes the pack
off and hands it to Peter he shouts at
Viggo
all right you blonde bimbo nobody Linda
plays me say hi to your kitten for me he
opens fire Egan and Rhea fired their
portal guns at the painting and hit the
detonate buttons a massive portal opens
up sucking everything into it we see
Vigo's minions fly by we see flying
debris a candlestick knocks jnos right
on the head and he passes out the
Ghostbusters in Dana hold on to some
pillars but shockingly Viggo stands firm
he pauses suddenly Viggo's countless
victims flown into the room
Winston shouts oh yeah keep going the
scourge the sorrow yeah yeah they know
who you are and boy do they have a bone
to pick with you
Viggo looks at them horrified have a
good one
Winston adds the ghost fly through Vigo
into the portal each one forces him to
stumble slowly he's pulled back flailing
and tripping until finally he's lost in
the swarming whirlpool shut it off Rey
shouts and boom show over I figure you
get a little bit with Dana and Peter
Yano shares amnesia and maybe the
painting is a wedding scene now with
Peter Dana and the others or something I
don't know
outside Peck confronts Venkman well I'm
afraid this is goodbye dr. Venkman
Dana is incensed you're not shutting
them down again are you no Peck says I'm
taking a desk job someplace quieter
someplace away from all this
supernatural mumbo-jumbo South Dakota as
Peck leaves ray asks Peter you think I
should tell them how many haunted Indian
burial grounds there are out there don't
ruin the surprise ray the gang runs into
the mayor Lennie looks like you'll live
to see your third term don't worry we'll
send you the bill now just a second you
ain't down here ray but tsin mr. mayor
we saved the city we saved the world
what else is there what about that the
mayor points to the Statue of Liberty's
standing in the middle of the road Peter
smirks ah um call a secretary she lives
to handle stuff like this they walk off
Winston passes the mayor and notes to
him just so you know that was all them I
was in another dimension he winks
flashes a smile and the end credits play
the Ghostbusters theme now one fun idea
might be a mid credit sequence maybe
after the closing montage or something
it's a few months later we're in a
hospital room outside the window we can
see the Statue of Liberty's back in its
right place but like covered in
scaffolding or something
Dana's just given birth and she and
Peter discussing names she jokingly
suggests Viggo junior and Janos on the
other side of the room ray Egon and
Winston are talking amongst themselves
ray notes that with Peter having a kid
we might end up getting short-staffed we
may need to hire a fifth member what
about you Dana you seem pretty good with
a proton pack Dana glares at him no ray
shrugs well there's gotta be somebody
cut to the firehouse the team is
adjusting a proton pack but we can't see
who's wearing it yet are you sure you're
okay with this ray asks you got ads just
to let you know there's a 10% risk fit
using a proton pack can increase the
likelihood of brain tumors we hear a
familiar voice its janine melnitz oh
don't worry about me boys she pulls the
blaster out of its holster
I've been waiting for this moment for a
long time she arms the blaster special
effects blazing Oh dr. Venkman let's
discuss my salary Jeannine runs off with
Lewis following behind wait you should
let me sit in on the negotiations I'll
make sure you don't get bumped up into a
higher tax bracket and roll the rest of
the credits and there it is
ghostbusters new - it's in the same
wheelhouse is the original sequel but
we're not starting over from scratch
it's got some scares and some ghost
busting for the kids and there's a few
themed attic elements to chew on for
adults
I'd say the overall themes are adapt or
die and facing your fears
Peter faces responsibility marriage and
impending fatherhood Dana faces her fear
that Peter might not be up to the
challenge and Ray and Egon well they
were already kind of developed as it was
but I'd plant their need to help solve
the mystery create new tech and help
Peter and Dana out
for them their fear is simply failure to
adapt for Winston it's a literal fear he
actually faces ghosts and monsters
straight on and uses his courage to
rally tortured spirits under the yoke of
ego this is one of those crossover
themes that kids ever afraid of monsters
under the bed can totally identify with
and Jeanine and Luis begin to learn the
tech in order to take on Slimer kids can
get on board with that I mean who the
hell doesn't want to play with these
toys on top of that we also get to visit
the ghost dimensions and see new tech
that's more impressive than a mood slime
cannon now would all this make a great
movie
one as good as the original if I'm being
honest with myself and probably not
would it be better than what we got
I mean I'll toot my own horn here
because that's the entire conceit of the
show and say yes but it's not like I'm
in love with it and that's the thing I
don't think anybody's ever going to
figure this out
Ghostbusters was a one-shot deal
zeitgeist a lightning strike that lived
and died in 1984 we're never gonna get
the original back hell we couldn't even
get them back in 1989 like the gritty
New York it was filmed in this type of
grimy adult 80s comedy that somehow also
appealed to kids is long gone now every
ghostbusters product has to run through
the Hollywood homogenizer to make the
blandest family friendliest product
possible Ghostbusters 2016 is in some
root cause of the franchise's disease
it's the symptom the final sad end
result of decades of bad franchise
choices brought on by the unintended
consequences of attracting a younger
audience and where did that start I
don't know maybe look at the film that
plays like babies day out crossed with
goosebumps you know the one that opened
with our heroes doing kids birthday
parties or maybe it was earlier perhaps
and this is the scariest thing of all
maybe it was the Real Ghostbusters as
amazing as that show is and I still
think it holds up the second the
franchise became a kids property it was
all over and that's a weird feeling
knowing that I myself by watching the
cartoon and buying the toys
helped defang this series for good so
maybe we have to face facts here there
was never going to be a sequel that
worked hell I wrote this treatment and
guess what I wouldn't want to direct it
and I certainly wouldn't want to touch
the 2016 reboot either and the new one
coming out well maybe I'm wrong and I
would love to be please dear God let me
be wrong but I'm not holding out much
hope
you just can't recapture this one
Hollywood you can only make it less
sucky perhaps this is why the best
spin-offs are the most far removed from
film itself a video game and a cartoon
perhaps that's where the franchise
belongs now but what do I know maybe you
agree with me maybe you don't let us
know and feel free to share your ideas
about what would make a great
Ghostbusters sequel
[Music]
you